can you just tell me what Leonard does
all right Leonard is attempting to learn
why subatomic particles move the way
they do really that's it well that
doesn't sound so complicated it's not
that's what Leonard does it that is a
beloved and brutally honest Sheldon
Cooper from the CBS comedy The Big Bang
Theory actor Jim Parsons has brought
Sheldon to life for the past 10 years on
this hit show and now he's also behind
the cameras executive producer and
narrator of a new show it's called young
Sheldon the series introduces us to the
eccentric scientists as a child
Ian Armitage stars as a boy genius and
the prequel to The Big Bang Theory in
this preview the premiere episode the
nine-year-old Sheldon and goes on his
first day of high school
oh dear yeah
that boy has an exposed tattoo he does I
wonder if he knows that's in violation
of the dress code speaking of which how
about we lose that bowtie why look
around honey none of the other kids are
wearing my crab sauce I know you won't
please trust mommy all right tell you
what you take it off and this weekend
I'll take you to radio show kids what so
go to Radio Shack we are pleased to
welcome my Parsons and Ian Armitage to
studio 57 what were you gonna say in so
I was gonna say you earlier asked me to
think of three words that were like
really funny you have three lines three
long pilot yes actually I have four okay
go ahead thank goodness all right go
ahead give me three lines go ahead first
of all um that girl's blouse is
diaphanous like this that means I can
see her brassiere okay second of all we
have mom when should I be expecting my
testicles your favorite that is my
favorite line in the pile where do we
also have for half so I'm sorry perhaps
I'll start a fad yeah yeah we saw that
one and last one when we think well
we'll go to gym and you think of the
last ones but yeah
I have Jim this was your idea you went
to Les Moonves and said wouldn't it be
fun to show Sheldon before what were you
thinking why did you think we're onto
something here could you really first
thing we were trying to think of it was
me and my production company anything
related to that we could take a show out
a web out and we were going with my
nephew we that was the first thing he's
a 10 year old he's 11 now in Texas he's
very smart and as we started talking
about it was like well this is
describing a young Sheldon or it could
be so I checked in with Chuck first of
all because I thought if he has any
interest in this I should talk to him
about it but I didn't think he would I
really thought I was like they would
have thought of this before this is like
they've been building the material for
it for a decade I mean we've had
anecdote after anecdote about young
Sheldon that we've talked to that big
Sheldon has talked about and but they
jumped at it and what they've done with
it is really miraculous in my opinion it
is its own show it's its own memory play
it's an origin story or you can say I
love how you don't refer to yourself as
what I call myself you clone yourself
Big Show The Big Show that's the nicest
thing I'll say about myself today
probably just big not old I also thought
of the fourth one okay thank you Ian
what did you when you would you've
started big little lies and so a lot of
people know of you but what did you
think when you got this character oh my
goodness I was so happy and excited that
it was like I was just it came sort of
as a total shock because I thought oh
yeah I get to do another audition I was
at my grandma's over Christmas I just
barely even memorized it and I I was
just like my mom filming it was probably
the best thing about it like and then I
got a callback so I was like oh well
that's that's pretty good so I went in I
I did it
and I met mr. Jim well you know who's
with you being an actor yeah you are
your mom you see it doesn't exactly run
in the family because my mom's not an
actress but my dad is an actor and you
just saw him this weekend yeah I did I
saw him in Hamilton but the only
difference is he's a theatre actor so
and I act in TV shows and stuff I did
actually do a thing it was like I was
called Millions
it was I'm blinking a workshop worked
but you know the thing that's so cool
about this role Jim is that for his
character for Ian's character you're not
just putting Sheldon's words in his
mouth no it's not like you're trying to
do adult words with a little boy no
one's been talking about a lot is that
it really is its own character in the
same way that because what you're seeing
is Sheldon how he became what we see in
the adult show yeah and so this is kind
of its own creature that he's portraying
here and there it overlaps but there's
also like we watch him discover things
like comic books we watch him discover
things like his clothes are gonna change
style as he goes through this and I
don't know it's like all the things that
you associate with Sheldon now you see
how they got there through him yeah yeah
and what's it like Jim because we are
used to seeing you in front of the
camera now I have this additional role
as a producer I'm very mediocre at it
there's nothing about you mediocre it's
very strange and it's taken a lot to get
used to even talking to another actor in
this case Ian's like giving direction
sort of I mean you know I just I've
never been someone who's comfortable
giving other actor direction and you
know I don't know what makes any other
actor tick necessarily and I don't want
to break it you know so um or him but uh
but he's very smart
no you're not actually you're flexible
and resilient yeah yeah good again
but he is just so easy to talk to is one
of the other things this actually takes
place in 1989 and you were not alive in
night I was not right right we were all
alive so where were some of the funny
things you learned about the 80s from
doing the show first of all the clothing
sort of took me by surprise because you
have a lot of things that would be
considered totally outdated and really
weird today and no cell phones yes I
feel like huge old coach things whatever
there and banks coming back to it ended
with you proposing that's right so we'll
find out did she say yes get an answer
tonight and in real life you've gotten
married after me I did congratulations
what took you so long to make honest
people out of each other on his menu and
talk well we're dating a long time Jim
almost 15 years now I think it was just
when we first got together and it was a
real thing between us and we knew it was
probably long lasting marriage wasn't a
possibility right and we went on so long
that even once it was it wasn't we were
like well we're happy though we haven't
but then we said what the hell let's
have a party
what the hell congratulate thank you
congratulate again yeah such a great
show after what the hell and Ian
Armitage young Sheldon you can see this
seasons 11 premiere of The Big Bang
Theory tonight children pick up
everything Jim at 8:00 7:00 central
that's followed by the series premiere
of young Sheldon at 8:30 7:30 central
right here on CBS more of our seniors
this morning on our podcasts on iTunes